bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d' europe hebdo
nous sommes à strasbourg au parlement
européen cette semaine gros plan sur la
réforme de la colère celle de la
commission européenne qui veut instaurer
un grand marché des quotas de pêche
reportage en espagne mais d'abord
l'actualité
faut-il annuler la dette grecque c'est
la question la semaine des émeutes au
coeur du berceau de la démocratie
le parlement grec vient de voter son 7e
plan de rigueur en deux ans et l'art
grec s'embrase
la potion est amère une nouvelle fois
baisse de 22 % du salaire minimum 32 %
pour les moins de 25 ans nouvelle baisse
du traitement des fonctionnaires
renforcement du fisc privatisation
d'entreprises publiques augmentation des
impôts
la ceni est sévère et ce n'est que le
début des sacrifices demandés par la
troïka pour débloquer une aide de 130
milliards d'euros une enveloppe
indispensable pour éviter la faillite
mais ouf les marchés sont soulagés à la
faillite
la grande méchante faillite le remède
n'est-il pas pire que le mal
la grèce entame sa quatrième année de
récession déjà un tiers de sa population
vit dans la pauvreté ou l'exclusion 21 %
des grecs sont au chômage un jeune sur
deux n'a pas d'emploi le nombre de
suicides a augmenté de 40% en 2011 la
consommation d'héroïne de 20%
mais l'important c'est la rigueur encore
et toujours la rigueur la rue accuse la
classe politique d'avoir capitulé pour
calmer l'explosion de colère des
élections législatives anticipées sont
prévues en avril
avec la crise économique la crise
politique
mais alors la solution serait ce
d'annuler la lettre grecque
alors faut-il annuler la dette grecque
c'est la proposition que certains
politiques font depuis quelques jours
pourtant pour en parler parce qu'elle
quand on nous a rejoints bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen au sein de ce parlement membres
du groupe des verts et surtout ancien
vice président de la commission spéciale
sur la crise alors vous êtes assez au
fait de cette question est ce que pour
vous c'est une solution d'annuler la
dette
oui ça fait même trois ans que
personnellement je le dis il n'y a pas
d'avenir pour la grèce s'il n'y a pas
une monétisation de sa dette donc une
annulation est en quelque sorte c'est la
banque centrale européenne qui reprend
ray prend dette la dette et qu'ils
remboursent les différents créanciers la
grèce c'est un tout petit parti de la
zone euro et donc ça ne mettrait pas en
péril les grands équilibres de la zone
euro si on avait fait ça plus tôt on
aurait aujourd'hui une situation
beaucoup plus est maintenant ça
n'exonère pas la grèce d'un certain
nombre de réformes puisque l'annulation
de la grée de la dette ça greg les
questions du passé et ensuite si c'est
pour recreuser un nouveau trou demain
qu'il faudra annuler dans cinq ans avec
le pas donc il faut en plus faire un
certain nombre de réformes et là on est
face à un double blocage idéologique
d'une part les réformes qui sont
demandées par la troïka -commission le
fmi et la banque centrale sont vraiment
de nature purement néolibérale
l'ajustement sur le marché classique à
l'air qui n'a pas forcément marché
d'ailleurs là où ça a été menée
auparavant et par ailleurs c'est les
réformes se heurte aussi à des certain
conservatisme au sein de la société
grecque par exemple vis-à-vis de
l'église orthodoxe vis-à-vis des
armateurs qui est la première richesse
en fait tout à faire vis-à-vis de la
halle
la non lutte contre la fraude fiscale la
capacité d'état grec à cause des impôts
voilà et on a les deux en quelque sorte
les éléments négatifs qui s'ajoute et
qui font que le plan ne marche pas du
tout et que toute la l'ajustement tout
l'ajustement et demandé à ce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas fuir ceux qui ne sont pas
privilégiés ceux qui ne sont pas riches
ceux qui n'ont pas de compte en suisse
et c'est donc les retraités les petits
salaires les chômeurs c'est parfait
milliards on estime par exemple à 16
milliards les sommes qui ont été entre
qui ont été retirés en fait des banques
grecques pourraient être placés à
l'étranger
ah oui pour éviter les taxations reste
sur les quelques d'années derniers jours
oui beaucoup plus en stock qui voulait
le chiffre dont on dispose qui est celui
du gouvernement grec sait que ne serait
ce que pour la suisse il y a deux sens
entre 100 et 200 milliards parce que ce
sont par définition des estimations
entre 100 et 200 milliards d'argent
grecs qui sont dans les comptes suisses
et qui ont échappé à l'impôt et donc la
priorité du gouvernement grec comme de
l'union européenne ça devrait être
d'aller chercher ces 100 à 200 milliards
pour les taxes et un taudis ion de 30 ou
40% plutôt que de diminuer les salaires
de ceux qui sont déjà à 500 euros par
mois
mais le problème c'est que ça risque de
faire jurisprudence après tout si jamais
on laisse la dette
si on annule la dette grecque qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on va pas faire la même
chose avec le portugal voire avec
l'italie fin c'est pour ça que
l'annulation de la dette doit être là
conditionnée à un certain nombre de
réformes
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande aux
grecs c'est d'une part des réformes qui
sont extrêmement injuste donc on peut
leur demander on peut conditionner
l'annulation de la dette à d'autres
réformes par exemple taxer enfin le
détail m des taxes foncières sur
l'église orthodoxe taxes et enfin les
armateurs lever enfin un impôt vous
certes l'économie informelle en grèce
c'est entre 40 et 50 % des enfants de
l'économie donc ce chemin là il qui
conditionne l'aide mais qui le
conditionne à d'autres réformes
il est possible donc il s'agit pas d'un
chèque en blanc en disant regardez les
gars c'est facile on vous annuler la
dette ya pas de problème on leur dit on
vous annuler la dette parce que de toute
façon il n'y a pas d'autres moyens et on
voit que depuis trois ans on y arrive
progressivement
sauf qu'on met énormément de temps et
qu'on aggrave la situation mais en
contrepartie on vous pose des exigences
qui sont elles justes et que vous devez
tenir
mais est ce que ça implique pas aussi de
réformer
la finance vous venez de sortir un livre
sur ce que les banques vous dise
et pourquoi il ne faut presque jamais
les croire aux éditions du petit matin
vous parlais justement de la réforme du
milieu financier
ça fait partie aussi des actions à
mettre en oeuvre non bien sûr
par exemple pour aller chercher l'argent
grec qui a fui vers les paradis fiscaux
par exemple vers la suisse ou vers le
luxembourg il ya des réformes clair à
mettre en oeuvre pour assurer la
traçabilité
donc ça j'en parle dans le livre comment
on peut lutter efficacement contre les
paradis fiscaux
il ya un modèle qui va être mis en place
en 2013 par les états unis par obama qui
écrase le secret bancaire
et je vois vraiment pas pourquoi ce que
obama fait en france et en europe
on ne serait pas capable de le faire
donc ça fait partie des réformes qui
pourraient aider la grèce évidemment les
réformes du système financier vont bien
au delà du cas grec
puisqu'il s'agit aussi de changer la
façon dont les marchés financiers de
manière générale fonctionne on les
agences de notation fonctionne dans les
banques peuvent ou non prendre des
risques au delà évidemment la situation
de mais là vous en parlait très bien
dans votre livre d'ailleurs qui est très
pédagogique sur ces questions on a on
assiste quand même à une totale
financiarisation les les banques en fait
enfin les les hedge-fund se font prêter
d'argent par les banques qui vont
ensuite acheter de la dette etc
enfin et vous souhaitez vous vous prenez
une réforme donc par le biais de dix
propositions
est-ce que c'est pas un voeu pieux au
fond parce qu'on se rend compte que par
ce biais là quand on voit les plans de
rigueur succéder au plan de rigueur on
n'a pas l'impression qu'on s'attaque en
fait aux véritables raisons de 2
de la faillite presque de la grèce alors
encore une fois sortons du cas grec en
particulier parce que la question de la
réglementation financière elle est aussi
valable en italie en france en allemagne
donc concrètement c'est pas un voeu
pieux parce qu'on voit que certaines
réformes
lorsqu'il ya vraiment une volonté
politique d'y aller peuvent marcher dire
que derrière les arguments des
financiers qui nous disent si vous
faites ça on va ailleurs si vous faites
ça on arrête de financer l'économie
argument que j'essaie de déconstruire
dans le livre les impressions assez
pédagogique des remercie quand on voit
que finalement ce sont pour largement
pour une grande partie des faux argument
ça libère le chemin pour mettre en place
des réformes politiques
à condition évidemment qu'il ait la
volonté de le faire et le problème
aujourd'hui ce ne serait pas une
incapacité structurelle du politique à
agir sur les marchés mais bien une
absence de volonté politique de régler
cette question c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui est donc prenons quelques
exemples qui marche ailleurs quand on a
la volonté politique de le faire
obama sur les paradis fiscaux partir de
l'année prochaine il ya plus de secret
bancaire possible pour tous les citoyens
américains quel que soit l'endroit où
ils vont ouvrir un compte en suisse au
liechtenstein aux bahamas volonté
politique
ils l'imposent nous en europe ce qu'on a
fait pour la première fois ce que n'ont
pas fait les états unis c'est
d'interdire les formes de spéculation
contre les dettes souveraines
je rentre pas dans les détails
techniques on n'a pas le temps mais on a
voté j'étais le négociateur en
responsable de ce texte là on a voté en
europe un texte qui va interdire des
marchés de spéculer sur les dettes
souveraines le temps de prendre cette
décision et que ça s'applique pour
adopter les décrets ce sera en novembre
par exemple au royaume-uni pays pourtant
libéral ils sont en train d'adopter une
réforme sur les banques
beaucoup plus ambitieuse que celle que
sarkozy à un moment donné avait proposé
donc on voit que si on prend des petites
pastilles comme ça si on va dans le tir
tout le monde dans la bonne direction on
peut réglementer la finance c'est pas
une question encore une fois ça c'est un
argument des financiers de dire vous
avez la finance s'est mondialisée
si vous faites en france de toute façon
on va ailleurs c'est faux j'ajouterai ce
que j'ai vu c'est le temps de vous
donner un exemple quand on a réglementé
avec les bonus des traders en europe
le lobbying des banques c'est de dire si
vous faites ça on quitte londres on
quitte paris on va à new york au même
moment où je négociais steak je suis
allé au congrès américain où les
américains négocier
sur les produits dérivés qu'est ce que
disaient les mêmes bancs aux américains
si vous faites ça on quitte new york on
va à londres la réalité c'est qu'on peut
pas passer du lundi de londres à new
york et le mercredi de new york à
londres
c'est faux c'est surtout ce que vous
expliquez en plus dans votre livre vous
déconstruisent est effectivement de
manière assez assez perspicace toutes
ces idées reçues qu'on a sur le système
bancaire et ça marchait bien je voudrais
qu'on parle d'une dernière chose il ya
une autre crise en fait qui secoue
l'europe et c'est en l'occurrence la
syrie et la répression par le
gouvernement assad de la population on a
fait un petit florilège des réactions
des télévisions européennes sur cette
question c'est une sélection qui a été
fait par ulysse lichtlé et aurélie
d'afas intervenir ou non c'est le débat
qui agite les nations unies la ligue
arabe puis style damas et demande la
création d'une force d'intervention
arabe onusienne une proposition
apparemment soutenu par la russie et la
chine
depuis moscou à côté de son homologue
qatari le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe a déclaré son accord
avec la proposition de la ligue arabe
sergueï lavrov a aussi rappelé que la
syrie doit accepter le plan c'est que
doivent cesser les violences de toutes
parts la chine appuie la proposition
tout en s'opposant à l'envoi des casques
bleus mais comme le précise la chaîne de
télévision russia today
la position russe n'est pas sans
conditions ni sans réserve
un des points cruciaux qui a été
mentionnée par le ministre des affaires
étrangères il faut un accord du
gouvernement syrien et ce alors que
damas rejette la proposition initiale
selon eux ce serait une ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures est très
inquiet que les nations unies ne soit
utilisée en ce sens et c'est également
le cas de la russe qui craint que les
nations unies ne soit un outil pour
obtenir un changement de régime et non
pas revenir à la fin des violences
au sein de l'union européenne l'appui
n'est pas vraiment franc non plus alain
juppé et s'opposent pour l'instant à
toute intervention militaire est à
l'image de ses homologues allemands
italiens le ministre des affaires
étrangères britannique reste très
prudent dans un avenir proche je ne vois
pas en syrie une intervention
occidentale sous quelque forme que ce
soit même pour le maintien de la paix je
pense que l'initiative doit venir
d'autres pays que des pays occidentaux
mais bien sûr si un tel concept était
acceptée nous le soutien de riom par
tous les moyens à notre disposition
pascal canfin est-ce qu'il faut
intervenir militairement en syrie
à très court terme non il y a encore des
étapes qui peuvent être prises d'un
point de vue diplomatique par exemple
reconnaître officiellement l'opposition
syrienne conseil national syrien exclure
définitivement tous les ambassadeurs ce
qu'aujourd'hui dialogue qui continue et
donc faire comprendre à l'assad qu' il
n'y a plus d'avenir pour lui toutes ces
étapes là n'ont pas encore été prise et
donc à l'image de ce qu'on a fait pour
le yémen avec le présidentielle
exactement ce qu'on a fait
progressivement je pense qu'on en est
encore une marge de manoeuvre pour
mettre une pression supplémentaire sans
aller à ce stade jusqu'à l'intervention
militaire même si bien évidemment on ne
peut pas l'exclure comme principe parce
que ça fait partie des mesures de
rétorsion et de pression possible mais
vous comprenez que l'on fasse appel à la
notion d'ingérence après tout quand on
voit ce qui s'est passé quand on a
intervenu en libye en irak en
afghanistan là on est quand même dans un
ordre des espèces de bourbier avec des
guerres civiles des guerres
confessionnelles
est-ce que intervenir notamment syrie vu
le risque de régionalisation du conflit
on voit déjà qu'au liban ça commence un
petit peu à être délicat on à l'iran à
côté israël israël qui risque d'aller
intervenir en iran est ce que ce serait
vraiment une idée non c'est pour ça que
jour d'hui à ce stade c'est pas
d'actualité parce que l'enjeu c'est de
faire confiance à la ligue arabe qui a
quand même pris des positions assez
offensive
habituellement offensive donc puisque le
jeu diplomatique bouge dans la bonne
direction
essayons de maximiser ce jeu
diplomatique
un dernier point sur le conseil de
sécurité parce que on voit bien à quel
point le conseil de sécurité tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui est totalement
archaïque et donc nous comporte aussi
europe écologie
eva joly dans la campagne en france
c'est une réforme de ce conseil de
sécurité supprimer le droit de veto
élargir à quelques autres pays
par exemple le brésil l'afrique du sud
l'inde d'avoir un conseil de sécurité
beaucoup plus représentatif de la
réalité géopolitique est passé à des
majorités qualifiées
là on aurait quelques lunes double
réforme qui ne serait pas négative pour
nous européens puisque on serait
toujours présent mais au contraire on
renforcerait le rôle des nations unies
parce que ce serait beaucoup plus
légitime et l'idée de que l'union
européenne est un siège au sein du
conseil de sécurité ce que vous
l'apporté elles n'ont ni totalement
favorable la question c'est est ce que
on a suffisamment d'unités sur les
positions politiques que l'on tient
entre l'allemagne la france et le
royaume uni pour faire en sorte que ce
soit une perspective à très court terme
honnêtement j'en doute un petit peu
dernière question on a très peu
justement entendu l'union européenne là
dessus catherine ashton est restée assez
discrète comme souvent mais quelle est
la position du parlement là dessus
qu'est ce que vous pourriez porter on
est en train justement de négocier cette
semaine une résolution sur la syrie qui
je pense sera assez largement
majoritaire dans laquelle on dit d'abord
priorité aux efforts diplomatiques
notamment ceux de la ligue arabe ceux de
la turquie
je pense que c'est important de le
reconnaître aussi les acteurs jouent
exactement dans le bon sens donc tout ça
est en train je dirais de coaguler pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une pression
supplémentaire et je rôle de l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est de soutenir toutes les
modalités qui permettent à cette
pression de la part des pays frontaliers
de faire sortir le régime tel qu'il
fonctionne jour merci beaucoup
pascal canfin d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous sortez donc aux
éditions les petits matins ce que les
banques vous disais pourquoi il ne faut
presque jamais les croire donc c'est à
lire et c'est un petit traité très
pédagogique de comment fonctionne la
finance aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous avant de rejoindre
kathia gilder et son invité alain cadec
direction vigo qui est un des plus
grands ports de pêche en europe là bas
sandra cerqueira a été rendre visite à
ces petits pêcheurs que ce soit les
industriels où que ce soit les artisans
qui voit d'un très mauvais oeil la
réforme que bruxelles est en train de
concocter sur la pêche
il est 5h30 du matin sous la halle
hanche à la grande halle aux poissons de
vigo la criée bien de commencer de
multiples espèces que seuls les habitués
identifie au premier coup d'oeil
il faut être rapide les plus beaux
poissons partent en premier
brillant et on le reconnaît l'auteur des
inspecteurs de la gendarmerie maritime
sont là ils vérifient que la marchandise
est conforme aux normes européennes et
contrôler la provenance des poissons et
leur taille
chaque poisson doit mesurer minimum 20
cm et là on botte se dépassent on est
dans une théière est qu ils sont 17 à se
relayer
c'est bien peu pour contrôler les deux
mille tonnes de poissons qui arrivent
chaque jour
s'il ya un rêve actions donnent une
amende s'ils font un procès pour retirer
le permis de pêche
on fait ce qu'on peut on peut vraiment
comme on peut ce matin-là leur présence
surprendrait presque
est-ce qu'ils viennent tous les jours
faire le contrôle dans parfois on voit
les vétérinaires aussi mais eux ils
deviennent rarement et dès le lendemain
la décharge des bateaux se fait sans le
moindre contrôle
aucune vérification des quotas de la
licence de pêche de la provenance des
cargaisons interdiction de filmer de
plus près 100 inspecteurs il n'est plus
possible de tourner la caméra dérange
sur le plus grand port de pêche d'europe
un tel manque de contrôle peut
surprendre
neuf cent cinquante mille tonnes de
poissons ont transité par viggo l'an
passé un record
la plus grande flotte celles qui
touchent aussi le plus de subventions de
l'ue eux plus d'un milliard d'euros ces
cinq dernières années
il dispose de beaucoup de nouvelles
technologies ces bateaux oui on est
justement en train d'installer un
nouveau radar beaucoup plus moderne ce
sont les aides de bruxelles qui ont aidé
à moderniser les chalutiers
celui ci comporte un gps une plate forme
satellitaire et même des sonars qui
traquent sans marge d'erreur les bancs
de poissons et à l'extérieur des filets
de pêche de plusieurs centaines de
mètres
les quotas attribués par l'union
européenne ont été gelés et le problème
de notre flotte en galice c'est qu'elle
ne dispose pas de quota suffisant pour
que notre activité soit la plus rentable
possible alors nous sommes obligés pour
continuer à travailler d'acheter les
droits de pêche d'autres pays
exemple avec ce bateau son quota a été
atteint et pour continuer à l'utiliser
son propriétaire espagnol a racheté les
droits de pêche d'une entreprise
française près un interdit cette
pratique mais elle peut parfois frôler
l'illégalité
l'union européenne a déjà épinglé
l'espagne pour sa surpêche
d'après cet écologiste certaines
sociétés de galice ont même été condamné
pour pêche illégale tout en continuant
pourtant à recevoir des aides tant que
les fonds européens seront en partie
distribué aux entreprises par
l'intermédiaire des région autonome
il en sera ainsi en galice le secteur de
la pêche est plus puissant que tout sa
capacité d' influence politique est
énorme
ce qui explique que les autorités
espagnoles les sphères et ferme les yeux
le pib de la pêche en galice et 25 fois
supérieur à la moyenne européenne
c'est un lobby considérable bruxelles a
très peu de pouvoirs pour infléchir
efficacement la politique des états neuf
espèces sur dix sont selon lui
surexploiter les poissons commencent à
manquer alors les bateaux européens tech
de plus en plus dans les eaux africaines
où les infractions sont nombreuses il
n'y a plus assez de poisson vous
comprenez il faut aller chaque fois plus
loin et jeter les filets chaque fois
plus en profondeur pour en trouver
pour que les mêmes t la politique
commune de la pêche est en panne
elle continue de favoriser les intérêts
économiques de quelques entreprises la
flotte industrielle ne s'arrête jamais
elle peut pêcher n'importe où là où il
n'y a pas de normes sanitaires de quotas
c'est trop de concurrence pour nous ici
on est obligé de respecter des règles
strictes le doyen des pêcheurs fulmine
contre bruxelles et sa réforme qui veut
créer un marché des quotas permettant de
les échanger et de les vendre
la pêche artisanale est moribonde il ya
de moins en moins d'emplois et avec la
réforme ou bien vont encore disparaître
il en est sûr si demain les quotas
peuvent se monnayer le marché de la
pêche profitera encore plus aux
industriels retour à strasbourg alain
cadec nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonjour bonjour député européen vice
président de la commission de la pêche
serait par ailleurs breton donc vous
suivez ces questions depuis depuis forme
depuis fort longtemps
alors expliquez nous d'abord comment
comment ça se passe dans le secteur de
la pêche actuellement expliqué nous
quelle est la politique suivie en
matière de quotas on a vu qu'ils
n'étaient pas forcément respecter ses
quotas
ça concerne qui actuellement est quel
est le projet que vous présentez là la
commission actuellement comment ça se
passe actuellement nous sommes sur la
base de la stabilité relative donc des
quotas ont été décidées avec des
antériorités de pêche qui sont donc
négocier chaque année en fonction de
cette stabilité relative et qui sont
proposés à chaque état et qui après sont
répartis au niveau des pêcheries c'est
la situation actuelle
donc la commission européenne propose de
changer cette situation pour instaurer
ce qu'elle appelle des concessions de
droits de pêche transférables ça paraît
un peu compliquée en gros il s'agit de
faire quoi il s'agit tout simplement de
d'attribuer un bateau un pêcheur une
certaine quantité de poissons à pêcher
un certain quota dont il serait en fait
en quelque sorte utilisateurs pas
propriétaire mais utilisateurs et qu'il
pourrait évidemment négocier avec
quiconque
c'est à dire que n'importe qui pourrait
venir lui acheter ses quotas de pêche
pour pouvoir les utiliser pour lui-même
alors vous êtes contre tout à fait en ce
qui me concerne et je ne suis pas le
seul dans la commission de la pêche du
parlement européen je suis opposé à
cette réforme parce que elle
déboucherait immanquablement d'abord sur
une concentration des droits de pêche et
donc aiderait plutôt la grosse pêche la
pêche industrielle et contribuerait à
détruire en quelques sortes la pêche
artisanale
alors la commission européenne explique
si elle veut mettre en place cette
réforme c'est parce qu'actuellement il
ya trop de bateaux pour trop peu de
poissons donc tout est surexploité
qu'elle veut au contraire favoriser
cette concentration dont vous parlez
pour une meilleure gestion des stocks de
poissons alors c'est à dire qu'elle se
trompe sur son raisonnement est
complètement complètement parce que
l'arithmétique est simple aujourd'hui si
vous voulez dix bateaux pêchent 100
tonnes de d'une espèce quelconque demain
un bateau pêchera toujours 100 tonnes
donc la mise en oeuvre des concessions
de pêche transférables n'est absolument
pas une réponse à ce qu'on peut appeler
un appauvrissement de la ressource qui
d'ailleurs reste à prouver
donc vous êtes contre en fait vous dites
que cette réforme va contribuer à
travers et par une concentration des
droits à une monétaire monnaie tard
isation en fait du système et donc c'est
une c'est une proposition ultra ultra
libérale alors qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui où nous a amenés
l'ultralibéralisme il est nécessaire moi
je suis un libéral
je suis pas un ultralibéral je suis pour
la liberté je suis par là je suis pas
pour la loi de la jungle donc et surtout
pas la loi du marché parce que ça c'est
mettre en place les camps les
concessions de pêche transférables
c'est offrir au marché la pêche
européenne et ça ne répondra pas aux
problèmes de la ressource
assad a profité à qui cette réforme 6-1
procédera à quelques grosses entreprises
éventuellement à des fonds de tensions
je ne sais qui mais en tous les cas pas
aux pêcheurs et pas aux communautés de
pêcheurs et pas au port de pêche de
l'union européenne
cette réforme a été mise en place
existant dans certains pays comme par
exemple en islande est ce qu est ce que
la bataille va t on a l'exemple parfait
de l'échec de cette politique de
concentration des droits et de
d'ouverture vous êtes allés sur place
vous même pour nous nous y allons dans
quelques semaines mais je me j'ai reçu
avec des députés de la commission
j'ai reçu le ministre islandais je me
suis quand même tu peu documenté sur sur
la question et on voit bien que c'est un
échec
c'est un échec total puisque il ya
désormais en espagne a très peu
d'entreprises qui ont concentré la
totalité des droits de pêche
donc ça veut dire que sur le plan social
c'est une catastrophe puisque des
pêcheurs ont perdu leur emploi et donc
nous nous souhaitons maintenir cette
activité économique et social qu'est la
pêche tout en préservant le la ressource
parce que évidemment jean placent
souvent cette expression qui est qui est
toute simple voire simpliste pas de
pêcheurs pas de paix sont pas de poisson
peu de pêcheurs pardonnez moi c'est
évident il faut d'abord préserver la
ressource est à dire conserver les
espèces
le poisson pour que les pêcheurs
puissent puisse travailler alors on
entend bien votre position à la cadec
vaut à votre argumentation
est-ce que ici à une position unanime au
parlement européen on est actuellement
nous sommes en discussion au niveau de
la commission de la pêche
il ya des ya des collègues qui font
partie de ce pays où il ya on a vu des
problèmes de surpêche comment en espagne
alors que disent vos collègues espagnols
dans leur ensemble
si si vous aussi vous citer la galice
c'est vrai que c'est une une région de
pêche par excellence valu plus grosse
région de pêche en europe il ya de
grosses entreprises
donc c'est vrai aussi que les collègues
galicien voir espagnols sont évidemment
assez tenté pour certains d'entre eux en
tous les cas de de favoriser la mise en
oeuvre des concessions de pêche
transférables mais globalement nos
collègues irlandais portugais donc
français comme je le disais tout de
suite du royaume uni sont opposés à ce
genre de mise en oeuvre pour vous tirer
la sonnette d'alarmé sur la situation
actuelle et il faut faire quelque chose
pour le secteur de la pêche qui n'ont
donc d'autant plus que je suis rahman a
cité que je suis convaincu que c'est un
repère que c'est une activité qui n'est
pas en crise actuellement la petite
pêche se porte assez bien en europe
il suffit de mettre en oeuvre des
contrôles c'est ce qu'on fait on a mis
des log book sur les bateaux on met un
certain nombre de patients qui sont
parfois insuffisants on le voit les
médailles dont je trouve que dans le
reportage c'est un petit peu exagéré
c'est vrai qu'il faut en mettre
davantage en place c'est vrai qu'il faut
être prêt il faut quand même rappeler
que c'est l'union européenne qui a les
eaux les plus contrôlées du monde
si toutes les eaux mondiale était
contrôlé comme aux européennes il y
aurait pas de souci pour la ressource
le problème c'est les pays émergents je
pense à la chine notamment et à d'autres
l'indonésie les philippines qui vont
pêcher sur les côtes d'afrique par
exemple et qui vont piller la ressource
mais c'est pas les flottes européennes
qui sont contraintes qui ont des ya
aucune aucun contrôle environnemental
sanitaire et sociale pour ces flottes là
alors que nous on ce qu'on s'applique
des règles absolument drastiques alors
alain cadec pour juste une dernière
question pour pour terminer il ya un an
sur ce même plateau
on parlait déjà de la pêche avec vous et
vous nous disiez que vous défendiez
l'idée d'un écolabel sur leurs produits
de la mer pour savoir concrètement d'où
vient le poisson que l'on mange comme
celle sur les lignes sobres et c'est un
élément qu'on va mettre dans la réforme
mais là je pense que tout le monde est
assez d'accord sur ce principe là le
principe de l'éco label européen parce
qu'il ya des labels privés mais qui ne
sont que des labels privés ce qu'il faut
c'est un label européen qui explique
bien au consommateur ce qu'il a sur
l'étal est ce qu'il va consommer d'où
vient le poisson quand il a été pêché
comment il a dépêché je pense que c'est
la moindre des choses et au moins ça
clarifiera la situation alors que chose
de très important
merci alors on appellera peut-être dans
un an si on se retrouve pour parler de
la tête ici même merci beaucoup avec
grand plaisir
alain cadec c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup à tous de nous
suivre émission présentée depuis
strasbourg avec nora ahmadi merci à
ulysse lichtlé et aurélie d'afas pour
leur préparation dans cette émission
très bonne si de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
bye